cientos de migrantes venezolanos
permanecieron bloqueados este viernes en
el puente simón bolívar que conecta a
colombia con venezuela en principio las
autoridades colombianas indicaron que
caracas les había informado que había
decidido cerrar el paso fronterizo
debido al alto número de migrantes que
han regresado a su país en los últimos
días en este es a porque sentir que
tiene tenemos nuestro total otra familia
allá y está en la tierra de nosotros
sentimos es tristeza porque el
presidente allá no le da la gana de que
nosotros pasemos sin embargo horas
después el presidente nicolás maduro
arremetió contra colombia y aseguró que
en el lugar sólo se estaba realizando
una actividad de desinfección para
prevenir más contagios de jovi 19
el gobierno de colombia en sus falsos
positivos mintiendo todos los días sobre
venezuela mintiendo y mintiendo dije que
hemos cerrado los puentes
internacionales que unen a colombia con
venezuela falso falso crearon común o
ridículo o sencillamente hubo una
operación de limpieza que duró dos horas
y mismo se restableció el paso
tranquilamente
se estima que desde marzo cuando
colombia declaró la emergencia sanitaria
unos 100 mil migrantes han vuelto a
venezuela y al menos 40.000 se
encuentran cerca de la frontera
esperando que las autoridades de caracas
les permitan el reingreso a su país